[Music]
sit there
said please
in 1993 Jacques de LA's Vision became
reality
or Europe without the old barriers
we're living loving working and retiring
across borders is easy energy
[Music]
a single Market that's improved life for
Europeans and businesses
opening up transport and tourism
energy and communication allowing
consumers and companies to buy and sell
safely
creating New Horizons in jobs and
education with professional
qualifications recognized across borders
and the Erasmus program offering the
opportunity to study abroad
I'm really happy that my kids now live
in in Europe they have more
possibilities to to travel and you know
broaden their rising and see different
cultures learn different languages
the single Market is constantly evolving
with Parliament leading the way
ending roaming charges
ensuring a fair open Digital sector
where platforms are accountable users
and their data protected
driving the green transition by backing
the right to repair a circular economy
and a common charger for electronic
devices
a keystone of a competitive autonomous
EU that can offer solutions to the
crises of today and tomorrow
is
economy
as it turns 30 the single Market
continues to boost prosperity and
increase opportunities for more than 460
million people across 31 countries
[Music]